en el acuerdo del brexit hay un punto
especialmente controvertido el protocolo
de Irlanda del Norte ha supuesto un tira
y afloja entre Londres y Bruselas desde
que entró en vigor el 1 de enero de 2021
Pero qué es exactamente este protocolo y
que lo hace tan controvertido con el
brexit el protocolo de Irlanda del Norte
nació para garantizar la salida del
mercado europeo pero respetar la
situación de la frontera de las dos
irlandes todos los países que no forman
parte de la Unión Europea están
sometidos a controles aduaneros para
hacerlo lo ideal sería Establecer un
control físico entre Irlanda del Norte y
la República de Irlanda Pero esto no es
tan sencillo existe una necesidad
histórica para mantener una frontera
invisible entre las dos irlandes para
fomentar la paz y cooperación tras tres
décadas de violencia en la isla
el protocolo quiere garantizar que siga
así por lo que estipula que Irlanda del
Norte siga aca las normas comerciales de
la Unión Europea y que los controles con
los otros tres países de Reino Unido se
hagan en los puertos nori irlandeses
evitando imponer así una frontera física
no obstante desde el mandato de Boris
Johnson Reino Unido quiere cambiar el
protocolo quiere eliminar los controles
de los productos con destino a Irlanda
del Norte y las normas Fiscales europeas
en el país para integrarlo más algo a lo
que la Unión Europea ha respondido con
acciones legales Aunque ha ofrecido
concesiones como reducir los controles y
la burocracia ambas partes han prometido
en intentar negociar lo más rápido
posible y quizás es llegar a un acuerdo
antes del aniversario del acuerdo del
viernes Santo en abril